hey guys ryan right here this video is
not going to be edited it's going to be
raw it's going to be one take let's see
if i come across good still we just past
fifteen thousand subscribers thank you
thank you guys that's awesome if you're
new to the channel welcome um but I
actually kind of wanted to do a little
sincere video right now it's uh you know
it's not all laughs you know 24 7
sometimes you gotta have a little bit of
heart and i'm already mocking my sincere
key um what i wanted to say was I've
been getting like a lot of comments ever
since we passed like around two thousand
subscribers a lot of people say
something similar to me about like I'm
going through a rough time or I've been
really depressed lately or this terrible
thing happened but your videos really
cheered me up and I'm talking about that
to let you know just how cool I am now
for saying that because I like a that
just it does mean a lot to hear that
like that's always very it's very moving
and so thank you if you've ever said
that to me we're planning on saying that
to me and if you haven't why haven't you
said it yet there's no jump cuts here
this is kind of weird um so I wanted to
say hello like I was thinking about I
was thinking about it today and I was
thinking about like everyone else who
comes on the channel 2 and whenever I
comment back and by the way I know I'm
late on comments it's because there's a
lot more now and not because like I'm
not commenting back anymore it's just
I'm still catching up but lately i was i
was thinking about like my was I've got
a text message I was thinking about how
everyone on the channel to you know can
definitely identify with all you guys
out there since there's something lately
I've been hearing a lot so I want to
talk about it but ya know like I'm not
gonna go into too much detail um but you
know personal life stuff last year for
me was not like it wasn't easy and so
you got all you guys you know like say
stuff that like stuff like that to me I
I'll say like I understand or something
but or let you know I really do
understand
like last year's when we started up this
channel like really launched it but
there's also some really rough stuff
like you mean you guys might've seen the
video back in the early days like my dad
passed away and a few days later
actually after that my grandma passed
away and then you know I had a hot
girlfriend with that [ __ ] wouldn't
downhill because Ryan is not gonna say
something stupid in case she watches
this video oh but yeah anyway last year
was a little bit rough and it was like
the hardest year of my life and I can
also i can also think like you guys out
there who have been subscribed to us
because we only ended last year with
about seventeen hundred subscribers but
with you guys who have been with us
since before you know like we even
passed a thousand it's like you're your
dedication in your comments like that
we're really uplifting and so yeah
especially you guys out there saying
like you're having a rough time like I'm
not gonna go in anyone else's story on
the channel but they all have like
everyone has a pretty interesting path
so you see in front of the camera and
you know we all we all know what it's
like to go through those rough times if
you have if you are having a rough time
and we happen to cheer you up thank you
Dad thank you for being cheered up it
means a lot and yeah that's all I want
to say thank you guys for everything all
you guys been in since the beginning and
all the new guys too and hopefully you
continue to enjoy our videos there's no
room for a dick joke here